Oh
Hello Tyra here, I'm here at BuzzFeed, and I'm doing throw back tea
Yes, this is not a false promise
Life-sized two will be on your screen whatever screen you use
This Christmas this Kwanzaa this Hanukkah this holiday season
2018 and
Life science is gonna be different so if you were a little girl or a little boy you were like oh my god
I love if she's so cute, and you have kids now that are that age
You might need to use a little parent discretion
Whether or not. They should be watching life-size - or not
Lindsey slides into those DMS
Mm-hmm I'd be seeing you girl
Mm-hmm I split into hers first to be honest because I was like yo
I'm producing life-size - but you down and she was like oh
I'm I'm down to the down like she's so down and so we're working on the script now
And I'm telling the writer like I don't want her to just have a cameo
I feel like you know she was just as important to life-sized
one as I was and so I wonder to have like a role like at least three four seems like and
I think she would play herself grown-up like Casey in life size and growing up
We'll see
I
Am on the search for a high-level
producer dj khaled that will remix or redo the be a star song dj khaled and
I'm hoping that whoever this producer is dj khaled would
Come and just make it the club banger where you just want to
shoot cannot do that dance dance
Shoot till you drop so that's what I'm looking for
I'd have to say cycle 1 because it was my baby. It was so new and it's so funny
I know first and last names of girls from cycle 1 Elise Sewell Shannon Stewart, Robyn Manning
You know it just goes on and on so yeah cycle one and back, then we were only doing one a year
so it was season 1 I
Remember there was this thing like kind of behind the scenes that we were like it's the heathens versus the Christians or something like that
I mean, I'm not saying that my girls that were not believers were heathens
But that was kind of the behind-the-scenes shorthand of like how to describe both sides
And I think a heathen one
But she was so amazing Adrienne was like on my list
I have a list of all of
The girls at the audition process and whether or not they should get in or not and next to Adrienne's name
I said no
And then she ended up being an alternate and then she ended up winning because she had some of the fiercest pictures all cycle
I've wanted to for so long so
over the years
I've created Dex
As you know it's like pages and pages of like something and you're trying to present something that somebody as to why they should do
Something I convinced them
For years have been saying we need to do a plus this was before it was called curvy plus tees and a plus-sized season plus
Pisces and then they keep saying no
So it's kind of like my hands are tied at least with America's Next Top Model for now
But who knows I mean the world has changed and we're no longer at the forefront of like the curvy girl thing now
We have Ashley Graham
And so many other girls and Instagram girls are blowing it up that our curvy girls, so maybe our new network might say yes
I got to pull out that deck again
I'm
Really proud of Lila and Winnie Harlow, so Lila came on top model
She was runner-up, and now she is running for it. She's been in G. Vaughn. She campaigns. She's on everyone's runway
She is killing it killing it killing it
She is truly the epitome of high fashion and all over the world really doing so well
She's not a Victoria's Secret model so you might not know her name, but everybody in high fashion does, honey
And if you don't need to like get with it Winnie Harlow is
Okay, I'm so proud of her because last year the Teen Choice Awards announced the top 5 that people could vote for for Top Model
top Top Model not America's Next Top Model, but like the best model of the Year Bella Hadid and Gigi Hadid
Karlie Kloss and
You know all the big girls of today and Winnie Harlow a girl that I found on Instagram
And put her on America's Next Top Model so she makes me proud every single day
Yes, I am vented smizing I
Wouldn't say invented the action, but I invented the word I was so tired of saying smell with your eyes
So I decided to shorten it so this is not smizing. It's just like dead eyes and
This is smizing. Are you ready? Can you handle it?
You need to peer into the lens as if you're you know kind of can't see that well you're a little upset
And maybe you're thinking about ice cream something makes you happy you're selling the magazine cover. You're selling the fact
That you're so fierce you're selling the fact that this wig is matted
But you don't want people to look at the matted wig you want them to look at your smile?
You're selling the fact that your knees are so ashy, but your smile is so fierce
They don't see the dryness that is below your thighs
it's nice I
Loved loved loved Beyonce coming on the Tyra show she would come all the time when Beyonce came
Beyonce came two hours before the show started and damn near stayed two hours after it was over like looking at tape and making sure
Everything was okay. She was such a perfectionist she needed all that time and I gave it to her
She didn't know I was looking at her, but I got to see her
Rehearsing and telling her crew like do this and do that and back in the day people thought Beyonce was just like yes
Ma'am you know I'm from Houston, and I'm just so nice and happy, and she's a nice girl
but she's a businesswoman and I got to see why she's so successful because she knew lighting sound every single thing and
So she was fine, and she always did a little something a little extra crazy on my show which was fine
There's this thing about like old shows coming back and getting insane ratings like Roseanne. Just came back
She got 23 million people watching that show so of course if the Tyra show comes back
We're gonna have like 35 million right so I'm tempted
Roseanne me and you Bing Bing
Okay Blake
Lively is an alien I
Have never seen someone be able to text somebody and make faces like what?
And they go action she puts her phone down and it's like Dan what I can't believe it you do what to me?
What you are whipped whatever?
Okay, oh, no, you didn't actually what?
Alien genius
Conventional Beauty
Boring I like a little something a little off a little eyebrow. That's a little higher. You know hair
That's a little uneven skin that has different skin colors eyes that are not just like oh my gosh
They're a lips that are like too big too small
Chin's that are you know a little too plain II foreheads that are too big I
Think things like that just make the world more beautiful when it's a little askew
The amazing thing about Will Smith is that when you're on set you hear him before you see him he announces himself. What's up everybody
Like such positivity so the fact that he was so happy and so amazing and so just like
Just delectable may like on set really great, and you know I learned that
Like this the show was a family like already not just a television family, but like a crew a family
They've been together for so long and hearing I'm the new one coming the said like
So I felt really awkward and I remember karyn Parsons
Asking me to go to lunch. Do you miss she didn't talk like that Hilary banks look like that?
But she'd be like Tyra to lunch
And I was so nervous and so scared and I would always say no because I felt like well
They're our family, and they don't want me, but here. She is asking me to lunch all the time so I learned like
Mel's into the situation Tyra don't be so scared
One of the most memorable not necessarily be but one of the most memorable was during the Academy Awards I
Was hosting the red carpet
For the actual Academy Awards themselves it wasn't like another channel or anything it was for the Academy Awards
And I went to Vera Wang and I was like Farah that trust is amazing
But it was a private visible zone like a wedding dress, and she's like okay
I'm gonna make it for you in Navy, and I was like maybe
Then I was gonna look like a host like I have on my dark dress, and I'm interviewing celebrities
And I don't wanna look like that
I'm gonna look like I just so happened that I could walk the red carpet or I can interview so I need to what color
And I convinced her to make it laughter
So I was on a lot of interesting lists that year some people said that Little Bo Peep lost her sheep up under my dress
Some said it was like a Disney Princess gone wrong
They were clueless, and they were lost to me. I was on the best-dressed list that year even if it was
There's so much that I have planned for the model and series stay tuned
I'm in a couple of months maybe in the next 12 months or so you're gonna see Madeline take a swerve on a curve
Like model and is gonna come to you in a way that
I'm most proud of
being first
like being the first you know black Victoria's Secret model on the cover to have a contract for Black Angel the first black woman to
Wear that fantasy broad diamond thing
Or being the first model female model on the cover of GQ. Can we pause record scratch?
People say oh, yeah tire was the first black model on GQ no first
Female model on the cover of GQ. Let's get her right I
Can remember it like yesterday, I thought she was gonna win
I felt like she should have won, and I'm still rooting for her
I think she's rooting for herself, and I think she's that girl is
Special even when I did that whole thing she was still trying to make everybody in the room Phyllis
She's still trying to make sure everybody cool. Good and
I'm still rooting for we all are but she's one for herself now. She's doing her thing
Or speaker
You Liang Liang